Good morning! Hello!
Nice scooter there, birthday boy!
A shirt that's funny
and also makes me feel bad.
Love you, Dad.
Has that always been there?
That thing will tell you
your life's potential.
-Where'd you get it?
-No idea.
It just appeared…
like magic.
You know what I got?
Superstar.
Well, I got dancer.
-Male model.
-Make it stop.
What's going on?
Why is everybody trying
to change their lives overnight?
-We're getting a divorce.
-The Morpho inspired us.
What was your card?
Healer.
A sign to engage in self-healing.
Or maybe it meant doctor,
as in the profession
that you do every day.
You asked if I was happy.
Are you happy?
I'm 40 years old.
I have no discernable talent
apart from whistling.
And I've only ever been
in one relationship.
I don't know if I'm happy.
I've never had to think about it.
Which was nice, actually.
It's not like I really believe
there's a magical machine
that can tell people
what they're capable of.
But literally everyone is trying it.
So they got together a week ago,
and now they're married.
That's fun.
Maybe everything is not quite as it seems.
That is deep.
I think I have everything I ever wanted.
Maybe you didn't want enough.
This machine,
magic or not,
is reminding people…
our lives have more than
one possible path.
We have been asking
where the Morpho came from.
What's inside it?
What we should be asking
is what's inside of us.
You're going to decide
your own life potential.
What about you, Mr. Hubbard?
What are you gonna be?